This time, we're not solving for x since there's no x in our equation. Instead,
we're solving for c, since c stands for the price per wiper set. We want to know
what values of c will make p equals 0. Now, this is in a general form for a
quadratic equation. That means, we can use the quadratic formula. And this may
be a little bit confusing because our variable is called c and what we do
usually refer to this constant term at the end as c. What's really important
though, isn't what we call these constants, rather, it's where we place them in
the quadratic formula. Once we have this all written out, we just need to
simplify and solve. Simplifying gives us these numbers. C equals negative
18,400, plus or minus the square root of 232 million, all over negative 400.
This is one of those moments where I'm very grateful for calculators as much as
I really do think it's important for people to be able to manipulate numbers on
their own. But I can't figure out the square root of 232 million in my head.
Because of the plus or minus, this is going to split into two answers for c.
Now, we can simplify what's under the square root and also divide both terms in
the numerators by negative 400. So, we get 46 minus 5 root 58 and 46 plus 5
square root 58. Let's look at the decimal approximations of each of these. The
first one is about equal to 7.92. And the second is about equal to 84.08. So,
these are our 2 solutions. Let's check out the graph for a second. So, here's
the graph of our equation for Grant's profit. P equals negative 200c squared
plus 18,400c minus 133,200. This is this lovely curve we've seen several times
now. Please note, of course, the scale on either axis. These bolder vertical
lines each mark 20 units or $20, and these bold horizontal lines, each mark
$50,000. So, let's look at our x-intercepts, and yes, this one does look like
it's just before 10. So, $7.92 makes sense or 7.92, for this point. This one is
just past 80, so $84.08 makes sense as well. So, let's keep in mind what we're
actually doing in problems like this. When we start with an equation for a
parabola like this one, if we want to find the location of its x-intercepts, we
can set the vertical coordinate equal to 0 since that's what's true at the
x-axis or the horizontal axis, the c-axis in the case of this problem. And then,
when we set that vertical coordinate equal to 0, we can use the quadratic
formula to solve provided that the rest of the equation is in the proper form.
The quadratic formula gives us the horizontal coordinates of those points that
have a vertical coordinate of 0. In other words, it gives us the x-coordinates
of the x-intercepts. Or in this case, the c-coordinates of the c-intercepts.